talk about those throw
you know sorry those four points of
mindset identity re-engineering
building the online business and the
shift in your dating life from
i mean you went from horrible crippling
one itis to
you're pretty much spoiled for choice
with everything that you do so the
question was around like this mindset
body
um like how did i transform this mindset
body women
money women stuff so is it okay if i go
into an exercise with the guys now rich
to kind of show them what happened for
me
yeah is this something that they can
follow along with and do themselves or
yeah exactly i thought i'd like to try
and do that if that's okay
fire away go ahead sell yourself okay
cool so
um anybody let me see if i can watch the
chat as well as we're doing this
but basically guys i'll keep an eye on
the chat for you so if this is okay with
your question that pops up then i can
just stick it up on the screen like that
yeah so this is what i did but i didn't
do this with the understanding i have
now
so this is the improved version if you
will
and this is the thing when we teach our
business coaches even though we teach
them like
hundreds of different things this is
always what they come back is like the
most useful
in essence now i've changed it to be
specific for guys but if you think about
guys and what they want to achieve
or what they need in life there's kind
of four quadrants
you've got mindset you've got body and
physical goals you've got your money and
finance life and then you've got your
women dating
sex life okay so hopefully the chat kind
of agrees that now you've got hobbies
and other stuff outside of that
but if you're missing any one of these
like life can suck a little bit you've
got plenty of money but you can't get
any women
sucks a little bit if you've got you
know women but you don't have your
health
or if you feel like you don't have
purpose then that you know so
these are i think the main ones in my
view
now i'm going to give these different
names so the mindset is psychology
body is physical money is environment
and women is relationships i don't want
to get into all the
boring academic stuff behind it but this
is based on the work of ken wilber and
he calls them
the um individual interior that's the
mindset he calls the body
the individual exterior the money side
the um
the collective exterior and the
relationship
side the uh collective interior
so basically we just found that these
words come up over and over again in
different languages so it's a good way
to view
reality of like what needs to be there
so this is
an exercise you can do to figure out
maybe where your blind spots are like
what was missing
for me so the first thing is i just want
you to pick a goal
so if you look at those four quadrants
just decide a goal and we're not going
to go into
like the keys of goal setting but
quickly just to help you
like make sure it's like present tense
specific and positive focus so you don't
be like
i want to stop smoking um
don't make it a negative make it a
positive so it might be
i have an online business that earns ten
thousand dollars a month okay or i have
a perfect like one point
v taper golden ratio 1.618 whatever you
want i weigh 180 pounds
just pick a goal that's the first step
then quickly we'll give you like a
minute to do this rich and i'll talk as
you do it
list out everything you need to achieve
that goal
so this is where i was so start doing
that now
so i thought felt i was doing absolutely
everything
to build my businesses felt like i was
trying to be the perfect guy to attract
the right women
and stuff like that and just not getting
the results i want
and so i want you to take that goal and
just list it all out
so i'll give a little bit of help as an
example you can do it for your goal but
just well people have time to do it
so let's say you wanted to build a 10
000 a month business it's what a lot of
people who
um i've worked in the past want to do
then
maybe you need an online sales funnel
okay that's what most people talk about
you maybe think you need a product
maybe you know you're gonna need some
level of accounting software
maybe you think you're gonna need a
community of some kind so list all that
out
rich what's going on in the comments um
well we got some people saying gold
looks good
exactly um you know they're just kind of
agreeing with it
you'll probably find a lot we'll just
pause or maybe be watching the rerun
anyway
so probably just let them pause it write
down their notes then they can just
resume perfect guys so if you're
watching this later pause it take as
long as you want to do it and then we're
just going to do the third step
and this is the final step of it but it
hopefully will bring some things to
light
now what you what you want to do is you
want to categorize your list
into the quadrants so the psychology
physical so i'm going to show you so
let's say to build a 10 000
a month online business so if what most
people will happen
and let's say yours was a fitness goal
you may have certain things like okay i
need workouts i need a nutrition plan
so just choose which one it relates to
most
so if it's for example to build the ten
thousand dollar
per month online business things like
a scalable training products and website
they're quite physical tangible things
something like a high converting sales
funnel you could argue that's in the
physical quadrant but really
you can't have a high converting one if
it doesn't take into account what
everyone else is doing same with your
unique offer
and then i can engage community for
example you that
involves other people so you can see
this takes a bit of practice but
you can start to separate out the
different things and what you may find
is
is that you've got most of your things
in one quadrant
okay and this is what a lot of online
training programs do which is what we'll
get to in a second
um i don't know if you want to comment
in the chat whether you add most in one
particular quadrant or if you've got any
questions about it
no questions showing up just some
comments here jeff's a women in mindset
for me goal of
refocusing priorities for me so um yeah
you'll probably find that
that you're gonna hover in a certain
area i mean probably around money and
women for the most part i think guys
especially if they've got their head
screwed on right
yeah this is slightly um i'm trying to
go
past the money in women i was just
trying to show those four of how they
relate to these four
so now you could have a specific woman
goal and now we're using these four
quadrants again so basically my point is
most of the time
you're missing one quadrant so let's say
you missed the psychology of building
the business you're going to need a ton
of focus you're going to need a ton of
energy and if you haven't considered
those things
and this is what most online programs
don't consider
they never even teach people who've
never been entrepreneurs before
how to have the level of focus and
dedication and energy that they need to
build that
maybe you missed good accounting in the
physical side business process
affiliates
great branding and so what you have to
do is you have to start
figuring out where the quadrants are
that you're missing in essence because
otherwise it's like a chair with three
legs you know it's
unstable the goal you're trying to
achieve
or it's like a car with a flat tire is
you're just gonna move slowly because
you're always gonna be fighting it
so maybe i should actually jump ahead to
some some examples of this rich before i
share the
next bit um i love how prepared you are
for this man i um
you know i was expecting to just kind of
chop up some ideas and talk about your
unplugging
you know from your we can do that
conditions back over to the alpha side
of thing
and uh no no no i want you to stay on
this because this is
because this is amazing like i love the
way that you organize stuff right
okay cool so guys let's let's actually
take it i was going to show you
something else first
um which i think will really help break
this down but i want to kind of keep
that away from
you until i don't want to give you the
answer ahead of the time so this can
unfold properly so let's say your ideal
body this quadrant approach right
so let's say you decide a cutting or
bulking program and you buy it
like athlean x or somebody like that and
that program teaches people how to
lose fat gain muscle get that perfect vt
taper
but they do it from a diet mentality
side
so i know someone who's a leader in the
manosphere struggled to lose weight for
ages and they got
real results with i think it's called
new more something which
is all focused on the diet mentality
they hardly touch nutrition or anything
so they're all focused there so you buy
that program you're all excited but and
you're learning all this new stuff about
diet mentality so you're getting your
psychological quadrant fixed
but then what happens if you are
surrounded by like the family's got
bad foods and so you're surrounded by
them
all the time so your environment sucks
you know these these are always talked
about in different ways but no one ever
really puts them together about why
they're all important together
so your environment quadrant isn't
stabilized then let's say
you start doing fasting or you do some
other stuff
and now you're getting all these
dopamine rushes but at the same time you
decide to quit watching tv because you
make all these habits and where you used
to get your dopamine rush
your brain's now going no we need
dopamine get something sugary so you've
got all these neurological cravings
or that you're scared of others seeing
you fail because you've tried this
before
so you're unstable in the relation in
the relationship with others quadrant
so you can see how this new program
that you're now telling you it's not
it's your fault that you failed because
everyone else got results it's not
really your fault
you've got all these other areas the
program never covered
to help you actually get what you needed
and what often happens is
the program creator didn't do this
deliberately they just had a shift in
all four quadrants
finally that they hit a brick wall and
they finally got over those other things
but they latched on to one particular
aspect making the change
and that ends up being a chair with
three legs it's a car with a flat tire
so
you'll either get no change at all or
it'll not last it'll come tumbling down
because you'll just grind through it for
a few months so
just to kind of chime in here for a
second just to put it in perspective
i see a lot of guys um on youtube
especially in the pre-roll ads i've i've
seen these ads run on my channel on
other channels
sometimes it's like wingman women
selling uh
courses sometimes it's like pickup
artists selling hey you know if you
regurgitate these three lines or
this one special text you know you're
going to get her to come over and blink
your brains out in 15 minutes
um the thing that you got to understand
about all these things
is you know you can have the perfect
delivery system the perfect regurgitate
these lines
and follow up with this text and after
she does this and do that
and i'm not a big fan of these you know
prescriptive
abcde i'm more a fan of the mindset
component which is why
i really like the way that you've
structured this hair as an example
because like somebody pointed out
earlier
this will work for pretty much
everything in your life but yeah
a three-legged chair is utterly useless
and that's what a
memorize these three lines in these four
four texts program is really all about
um if you haven't got your you know your
mindset your physical
you know your environment all the other
stuff haven't got all your ducks lined
up
it's all going to collapse on itself and
it's no surprise why some guys don't get
good results when they're buying these
hey
get my wingman course or some like
that right yeah
exactly and i'll i'll touch on i want to
unpack the manosphere a bit about where
guys are focused on not just one
quadrant but even a subsection of one
quadrant maybe we should go to that now
or i can just show a few more examples
yeah which whatever you decide is best
you know
we got yeah we got another half an hour
to go so cool i'll just go quickly
through this let's say the build a
business one because a lot of guys i've
worked with or even when
um i didn't used to work with guys when
it was just a full personal growth brand
a lot of people wanted to start their
own business
so let's say you buy a business startup
or business growth program course from
like sam evans alex becker
somebody like that so they give you all
the business growth ideas and what to do
brilliant you're all excited you've got
all this stuff but
then you hit these limiting beliefs
around money that limit your success
so now you maybe you think you don't
deserve money or that money or wealthy
people are bad
so that's an obstacle in your
psychological quadrant you also got low
energy
so you struggle to motivate yourself for
the challenges ahead because you're so
tired
that's a physical quadrant thing let's
say you feel that
if you do get wealthy and successful
you'll lose your family and friends
because you'll be more successful than
them
then now you've got a problem there or
maybe if you've got a partner
you feel guilty for working on your
business when you should be spending
time with them should be
being the belief you created in your
mind so
you again you've got this great course
and you're not getting results
and you're blaming yourself but it's not
really completely your fault when you
didn't know all this other stuff they
just told you oh this is all you needed
to do
when actually there's quite a few
different things you have to get in
place
that made the shift so maybe someone
else who's selling that business growth
course
they finally just said they hit such a
brick wall maybe they were like me where
they were thirty thousand pound
taking out loans of thirty thousand
pounds and they said i don't care
what the facebook comment says i need to
advertise and i need to earn some damn
money
so i'm getting over that limiting belief
they just did that but they don't put
that in the course because they think
it's how they structured the image on
the facebook ad
okay so this is where it causes massive
problems
it's a car with three flat tires it'll
slow you down
another one really fast improves
self-confidence so
psychological quadrant that's where you
want you want to build better beliefs
but what happens if you've got a fight
or flight response triggered too easily
then you've got a problem in the
physical quadrant because you're feeling
anxious or
high alert all the time what if you've
got an angry boss
and that's putting you down or always
putting you on edge in the job you're in
it causes and these problems and
destabilizes it all the time
because all the quadrants are going to
affect each other
okay so hopefully you can see now how
most mainstream
products that oversimplify things and
the only reason i want to share this is
a lot of guys get into so much guilt and
blame they're not where they want to be
and yeah we probably can all do more but
it's also
not entirely your fault because
just and it's not the program creators
fault they just don't know this stuff i
was very unique to get
an insight like peek behind the doors of
working in this leadership development
company
that really helped uncover this so i
just thought it'd be useful to share
that stuff
and you may have experienced that in the
past um
have that i don't know in the comments
if anyone's done that you know maybe
you've spent thousands on courses and
self-development
or marketing stuff or business stuff and
something just keeps holding you back or
you haven't got the results that you
really want
um and know you deserve yeah
um can you can you take us over to the
manuscript stuff so that it kind of
yeah i'm really excited strongly with
these guys because they know that
they're more
more familiar with that than they are
anything else for the most part
yeah i'm super excited to share this um
so this is something i just created
recently
to break this concept down more so we've
obviously got the manusphere just for
the time being i want to replace it with
the mana square so if we have these four
quadrants
that hopefully we can all agree maybe we
should have got more agreement
i can't see the chat while i'm managing
screens and all sorts hopefully we can
all agree these are the
like four really important pillars for
men
yeah okay good rich we'll use you as the
the king and leader and you can now
verify it all
to whether i'm talking nonsense or not
and so basically
if we now um oh so we've got psychology
physical relationship environment
but now let's dive a little bit deeper
we can break mind to set down
into that like even further so
if we go into like the psychology side
of mindset so we've gone even deeper
we could look at things like mindfulness
emotional intelligence other stuff on
the physical side of mindset if that
makes sense it can get a little tricky
imagine this you've got kind of
self-image on the relationship with
other side of mindset you've got tribe
on the environment and like what it
means to be part of something bigger
in the mindset you've got kind of
purpose and meaning so we can break it
down
further on the body stuff we've got
performance health
longevity aesthetic so you can see how
aesthetics
is part of the body quadrant but it kind
of relates to the relationship with
other side
because the aesthetics is what you want
to
be to attract the women that you want if
that makes sense
so that quadrant there i don't know if
you can see my mouse
of body kind of relates to the
relationship with other side here
longevity kind of relates to you
surviving in your environment that kind
of thing
same with money we can break it down
into okay well you've got your expenses
your budget your biggest expense is tax
probably for most people you've got your
income you've got your investments
you've got your debt
you've got and then in the woman
quadrant you've got things that people
talk about you've got your frame
you've got game that you need to be able
to do you've got being able to actually
date and get to sex you've got the red
pill
smv type stuff in here as well so
you can see the red pillar stuff is in
the environment
section of the woman part if that makes
sense um
because they're helping you understand
and navigate the
the environment and what's happening
there
so this is where it might start to make
more sense and why
we struggle so if we take the mindset
quadrant now
obviously for each quadrant there is so
many different people you can choose
from i've just chosen some very well
known ones
and who i consider very very like good
in many ways
at what they do um so for example the
mindfulness you've got people like sam
harris
for the tribe section obviously we've
got our very own
richard cooper who's building you know
the one percent the entrepreneurs in
cars and everything like that
and even though like many of these guys
will do multiple things so rich talks
about business and all this other stuff
i've just tried to give the ones where
they are like the top dog
in in essence um or at least what they
focus on the most
so lewis hoes example wrote a book about
the mask of masculinity and whether you
think that it's good or not
his focus is the self-image side of
things in that book a lot
jordan peterson like purpose and meaning
on the body side so the performance
you've got people like tim ferriss
health
dr michael greger credit nutrition facts
dot org
ben greenfield on longevity aesthetics
you've got so many you've got athlete x
you've got all the fitness people i just
had to choose somebody
but i'm just trying to show you as an
example
you go and buy jeff cavaliere's athlete
x program to learn how to build like
build the body you want
and it's a small section of one
core pillar that isn't taking into
consideration everything you want as a
man that doesn't mean you shouldn't do
it
at all because it's great stuff you
should just go in there with realizing
you need to support it with the other
quadrants
so if we look at the money one on the
expenses we've got people like andrew
henderson of nomad capitalist seven
people on taxes
alex becker teaching about online
programs and doing that graham steffen
on investments dave ramsey debt
and budgeting and all that kind of good
stuff and then the women's side
you've got guys like black dragon caleb
jones on the sex dating and
again caleb talks about all kinds of
stuff
and um business and all sorts but he's
brilliant at that kind of section i'm
just showing you some examples you've
got rolo on the red pill
paul benjamin on the frame thing uh
who's part of the one percent who's
absolutely fantastic
john sonmez i also had myron gaines down
there in the game section
i don't know where to put everybody so
there's lots of other people and choose
your favorite one
and some of them include multiple mod
multiple quadrants
but some are very focused and niched as
well but the point is
is you need to realize that if you're
going to get to where you want
that you have to take like a full
quadrant approach
and hopefully what you we did at the
start the exercise you saw
that there were blind spots to what
you're doing
and so it's really really important to
be able to see that and realize that
that's what you're going to need to do
in order to get to where you want to be
otherwise it's the chair with three legs
it's the car with three flat tires like
we've been saying
you